what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so with regards to Danny ran the
iron fist what I want to do is I want to
put spider-man on hold for a few weeks
or it's not gonna be super long it might
be like a you know three four weeks
something like that and I want to cover
Danny Randy iron fist and the reason why
is because I really love what Matt
Fraction is doing with like via mortal
iron fist or at least what he did only
ran for 24 issues it wasn't a really
lengthy series it's not like it went on
for a hundred some-odd issues it was
pretty short but it was basically like a
wholesale reworking of the iron fist
mythos and the reason why you know as we
kind of get into this origin is because
this origin story was kind of dated and
it was really just kind of Matt Fraction
saying hey look we're just going to
rehash the origin and we're just going
to throw it out there and that's usually
what Marvel does one of the things when
it comes to origin stories of different
characters and comic books one of the
things that differentiates Marvel from
DC is that a lot of times DC has like
timeless characters right they have
legacy characters Batman Superman Wonder
Woman and those origin stories almost
always stay the same the only real
exception to that right now is what Greg
Rucka is doing with Wonder Woman where
he's basically going back with the story
the lies the truth and year one where
he's going back to he's just kind of
like redoing the whole origin story of a
Wonder Woman probably put the upcoming
movie with gal gadot but the idea here
is that with iron fist with Marvel
Comics Marvel doesn't usually do that
right like Marvel will sit down and
they'll say okay DC will release Secret
Origins worse like hey guys here's a
three-page origin story of this
character for those who don't deserve
like a whole origin end of themselves in
their own comic books with Marvel
they're just like hey this characters
been around for thirty years so just go
read the old origin story by Stan Lee or
Jack Kirby or Roy Thomas or something
like that go read the old or some way
back then they don't usually retell
origins
sometimes they will but they usually
don't don't just say like the x-men have
been around for so long the origin story
of the x-men is just the same Charles
Xavier made the team at one point a long
line and you don't really see like an
updated origin for them it's kind of
weird it could cause some issues in
terms of like updating characters for
the modern times but what uh what what
Matt Fraction dies with this is he says
okay look here's the origin story of
iron fist Danny Rand and then with the
immortal iron fist story is basically
reinvigorating and building the whole
land
and so what kind of get to that once we
actually get into immortal ion fists
itself but for the origin story because
what we do here is we just kind of pick
up with iron fist more or less going
across like this test really just
undergoing the test with regards to the
city of Kunlun or I guess Kunlun however
you want to pronounce it but the idea is
that he's more or less proving his worth
to be a member of the immortal City now
the reason behind this is because of the
fact that with Kunlun it's like one of
these mystical cities but you can't
really access through normal means and
what I mean by that is Kunlun is
effectively a pocket dimension that's
really what it is those of you guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics you have
like the main universe right let's just
Rahl the main stuff takes place but you
have these little pocket dimensions like
Asgard Kunlun the realm of assist oh
also known as health so you have these
different little realms and territories
that you can access but you usually have
to go through a portal you can't it's
not like crossing the street it's not
like walking into a building you know
it's not like going into another country
you can only access it through certain
means now in terms of how that's done
well basically get to that once we get
to be immortal iron fist because Matt
Fraction basically revamped that entire
system and so it wouldn't really make
any sense to tell you how to do it and
then turn around and say now that
doesn't matter and so we're just going
to kind of cross that bridge when we get
to it but for the most part of the whole
combat scene in the whole training
situation is it wildly important is just
kind of giving us something to do or at
least showing us while Danny read what
he what he's doing at the pond while
he's going back over his origin and
really that aspect of the origin is what
I want to focus on so what we do is we
pick up really with with Heather and
with window Rand and Danny himself of
course swindle Rand being the father now
Danny Rand really on this trip with his
parents along alongside Harold Meacham
is designed for the purpose of Wendel
Rand trying to re access to and live you
know the idea that window ran had access
to somewhere along the line and the
result is that he's trying to find a way
back now window Rand himself is a
business partner alongside Harold
Meacham and Rand Argus heralded Meechum
incorporated a Rand incorporated NSD
idea they basically run a joint company
together the issue with this is that
Harold Meacham's motivations are very
selfish but they're twofold in the sense
that one he wants to marry Heather ran
like he wants that he wants her to
himself but he also wants to get rid of
Wendell R and so that Harold can have
the company all to his own it's just
it's classic greed and that was really
the way these stories are written back
in because remember this is just a
reimagining of the old Roy Thomas story
from way back in the 1970s when iron
fist first showed up and so because of
that this is really just kind of the
idea that that it kind of falls in line
with those stories the Wade
written back in so some aspects might be
a little bit hokey but the point we'll
get across in the sense that we're you
know window ran kind of slips on a piece
of ice and he basically reaches out to
hiromi-chan to save him Harold Meacham
says no and he basically just allows
window ran to fall to his death now in
response to this of course we pick up
with the most logical scenario right I
mean he got Danny ran freaking out you
have Heather ran freaking out but if I
you think about this is that we're told
again Harold's entire motivation in this
particular instance it's to marry
Heather to say hey look now I have you
all to myself
come to me and that's one of the dated
aspects of this story like you wouldn't
really see something like this right now
in Marvel Comics cuz people would look
at that and say what a stupid motivation
but back in the nineteen sixties and
back in the 1970s that was just the way
comics were written they were written
for a simpler time we didn't really have
like these huge grandiose major
difficult plot threads but they were
popular people liked them
that's why the x-men were so huge
because this story predates the you know
the whole uncanny x-men story as was
written by Chris Claremont and so Chris
Claremont kind of ushered in that age in
Marvel Comics with soap opera like
stories with plot threads that would go
on for five years before they were ever
resolved and so the idea here is that
with with with Danny Rand basically
making his escape alongside Heather
really just kind of running away from
from Harold Meacham Carroll's idea is
fine if you want to go then go and the
reason why is because there's no reason
to believe that either you know Heather
or Danny would survive so basically in
the Himalayas like they're out in the
middle of no man's land I mean whether
it's you know the animals in the area or
whether it is the environment you know
they're going to die regardless you know
dies in the elements will die because
they're eaten and we see this come to
fruition with a pack of wolves of course
you know we're where Heather tries to
retreat with her son they eventually
come across the bridge and of course
like any good parent she says go run
just keep on running and she tries to
hold the Wolves off now of course
cutters killed in the process and it's
at this point that Danny Rand is
basically rescued by the occupants of
Kunlun now we're not really told how
they get there and we're not told how he
gets to Kunlun instead all we do is just
pick up in the city of Kunlun proper
issue or just this place stay access and
so because of this we end up joining
with this idea of Danny Rand going
through his training session now
something that I want to kind of point
out here is this this notion that back
in the 70s when Kunlun first popped up
that it really was just like a like a
place you could go to but that's the
caveat to all of this is Matt Fraction
is going to come back any space is going
to say none of that's really the case
anymore
none that is the case of the city of
Kunlun so you can't simply just go
through and walk to it that it's this
sort of this city that you kind of have
to access by virtue of our order so my
dad it's one of the seven mystical
cities of heaven and stuff like that
we'll get into that once we get into a
mortal iron fist but the fact remains
the training sessions of Danny ran were
wildly intense I mean from from the
youngest age you know when he was when
he was extricates I'm eNOS head was
shaved
he was very militant he was trained in
some of the most prodigious forms of
martial arts it got to the point where
he was probably one of the greatest
martial artists on the planet the issue
with this is that as time progressed his
hankering for revenge remained he wanted
to see Herald Meechum destroyed he
wanted to bring everything down around
him the other half of this is that he
still had a desire to improve himself
for more power now one motivated the
other it's really what was done this
whole particular story in a sense that
with Danny Rand his motivation for
defeating Herald Meechum was his
motivation for becoming a better fighter
it's not like he wanted to be a better
fighter just for the sole purpose of
improving himself because he just wanted
to see how far he could go it was all
motivated by revenge that was really the
driving force behind this but the more
that he learned the more he wanted to
know the more he wanted to learn the
better he wanted to become and that was
really one of the things we just kind of
stood out as one of the most prodigious
fighters put in the realm of Kunlun
really is one of their best warriors and
so what had happened was he had went to
the head of the city of Kunlun a guy by
the name of Yuki and said I want to know
more I want the the greatest test that
you guys have to offer and the greatest
test came in the form of the Dragon Lord
known as Shula I used to think that's
how you pronounce it but the idea is
that Shula was a dragon it basically
protected its molten heart and if
somebody were to be able to defeat the
dragon they would in turn be able to
access the most of the heart and in turn
make themselves be Iron Fist and that's
exactly what happened where Danny ran
defeats this dragon basically takes its
brand branded onto himself healing him
of course the Dragons mark on his chest
from here he basically goes into the
Dragons molten heart and begins punching
his way through and essentially
accessing these powers now as something
to point out here is that Danny Rams
abilities are not really external the
molten heart of Shu Lao essentially
allowed him to basically channel his
inner energy and that's really what the
what the Iron Fist is the Iron Fist is
not an external power source that he
draws on is Danny Rand channeling his
own energies and then using them for the
purpose of creating an iron fist now
they also ran some durability you know
they also grant super you know
restraint to a degree different things
like that but his iron fist is not like
this all-encompassing thing that
destroys everything that comes across he
can knock out like Colossus for example
but that's about the extent of it it's
not like he could punch a hole through
Captain America's shield
you know it's not like he could dent
adamantium or something like that he
can't shatter Thor's hammer it's just
designed to make Danny Rand
formidable and that was really the basis
behind the standing Rand was not
designed to be some cosmic level
character he wasn't designed to have the
iron fist and then go on to be like a
member of the Avengers that saves the
world from like some Celestials or
Galactus or something like that it was
never anything like that he was designed
to be a street-level character that's
one of the reasons why he was rolled
over alongside Luke Cage and became
Heroes for Hire he's a great fighter but
at the end of the day he's no Captain
America and so because of this what the
story does is it just kind of fast
tracks a little bit to the introduction
of a guy named sighs now what's in this
origin story site was no big player he
was a small-time guy what had happened
as Harold Meacham had learned that Danny
Graham had survived the Danny ran had
returned in New York and the intention
of the anti ran was to kill Meacham and
so because of this this kind of gives us
a little bit of a flashback for after
this whole training session that we had
the beginning of the story after this
whole you know instance where he's
facing off against these various foes
he's proving his worth he's given the
option by UT to basically stay in Kunlun
eat of the fruit of the Immortals and
basically stay there forever like never
leave Kunlun but live for eternity
however Danny Rams desire for revenge
sent him right back to New York he
basically said no I don't want to stay
here now the cool thing about this and
the reason why this is being done by by
faction is while this origin story is
being updated it's because of the fact
that this is going to basically be the
basis behind everything that Matt
Fraction does where he's essentially
going to revisit this origin story and
he's going to say Danny Rand was not the
first Iron Fist Danny Rams father Wendel
Rand had a huge role to play in his
discovery of Kunlun it was a lot more
than him just saying I was there once
and now I want to go back it was never
like that there was a lot more going on
to all that that's why I say you know
fractions run of an immortal Iron Fist
is huge because it grabs so many
elements and it really just kind of
brings them all together and makes this
cohesive story that expands on
everything that we know it's almost like
a miniature toned down version of what
Jeff Jones did with a Green Lantern and
so again Danny Rand is able to defeat
site click fastened in a hurry we see
him of course using his iron fist for
the purpose of defeating spud again it's
not a great big huge deal here it's
basically just Danny ran
at least the origin story kind of
picking up with his own individual
adventures back in the 1970s and 1980s
when he eventually went on to fight
Harold Meacham defeat Harold Meacham and
then eventually become part of the
Heroes for Hire alongside a Luke Cage
but yeah this should give you a pretty
good idea of where his characters coming
from but again this is just kind of like
a building block this is just a small
point and then everything will build on
top of this and it gets really cool when
we get to like the seven cities of
heaven because then we logically find
out about like all these different
fighters from these different cities
that are almost basically like Danny
Rand it's almost like the equivalent of
a immigrant from these different cities
it's like from Harry Potter you know
when you have like the novel's different
houses remember what they were but yeah
those two houses showed up you're in the
whole tournament thing and it was really
cool the everything all the way the way
it all played out but if you guys are
new here to come and explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob cork you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah leave a comment down below let me
know how you guys feel about iron fist
on necklace because I'm really hyped
like I'm really excited to see what
direction they go in I feel it'll be a
lot like this where it's very grounded
but I think it'll be pretty awesome in
terms of how its how all is up going
down but whatever being said the guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end and we'll catch you all in it please
[Music]